a light in the darkness outside a house
which signals welcome
a tiny glow in the dense forest near
poland's border
green has become the color of compassion
an invitation for migrants and asylum
seek is hiding from the authorities
europe's oldest forest may look
enchanting but this vast territory is
full of swamps rivers and animals
these photos were given to sky news by a
local resident who's part of an
underground network bringing supplies to
men women and children who often spend
days in the forest after crossing the
border the migrants are usually freezing
cold and disorientated this place must
be especially frightening at night
and it's in the darkness that we talk to
adam we promise to keep his identity
secret he's part of the grassroots
movement of people working in the forest
they they don't have water and food
usually for many days or have only a
little of water
some of those tried to drink water from
rivers and swamps i recently met a
group of people from iraq without the
boots
and
of course they
they are also completely lost
and the need for help is growing
thousands are still massed on the
belarusian side of the border an aim to
evade the polish guards and make it
through to the woodland between the two
nations
olivia coordinates vital supplies to be
delivered to the forest including
nappies and warm clothes for children
the volunteers find the work emotionally
draining i think guys who go and it's
many of them are you know grown-up men
many of them cried many times and i
think some of most of us have seen it
have seen it for the first time when
their friends cry
over
strangers you know we don't know these
people we usually see them the story
like such an impression that is
it's unbearable
they say they're stepping in to do the
work the government the state should be
doing whatever the politics of
immigration they simply want to help
michelle clifford sky news poland